bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
luís muñoz por santiago ariztía en esta
emisión nos quedamos en colombia para
hablar con francia márquez candidata a
la presidencia en las elecciones del 29
de mayo con su movimiento soy porque
somos que está apoyada por el partido de
izquierda polo democrático y participa
en el pacto histórico va segunda en las
encuestas para liderar está con esta
coalición en los comicios presidenciales
por detrás del candidato gustavo petro
además fue ganadora en 2018 del premio
goldman el considerado novel del medio
ambiente después de una larga
trayectoria como lideresa social en su
comunidad en el departamento del cauca
en el sur occidente de colombia francia
márquez bienvenida a la entrevista de
france 24
muchas gracias luis un abrazo ancestral
para todas las personas para usted que
ven france24 gracias por esta entrevista
en 2018 precisamente cuando recibiste el
premio goldman tus primeras palabras
fueron soy una mujer afrodescendiente
esto además en un país como colombia
donde alrededor del 10 por ciento de la
población se considera a sí misma afro
es destacable que por ejemplo esto sí
que se ve en la selección nacional de
fútbol pero no en las estructuras de
poder mi pregunta es que hace falta para
que un país como colombia tenga una
presidenta afrodescendiente y porque
debería ser francia márquez
bueno yo creo que lo que hace falta es
que esta sociedad reconozca
primero que hay que ir de la resistencia
al poder que hay que transformar las
estructuras de opresión racistas
patriarcales y clasistas que no han
permitido a la mayoría de los
colombianos y colombianas vivir en
dignidad que nos ha sometido años y años
a un conflicto armado y aunque se hice
un avance en términos del acuerdo de paz
firmado entre el azar y el estado
colombiano hoy todavía
el miedo y camina por los territorios
empobrecidos razón racializados de este
país y eso nos implica entonces pasar
esa página de la muerte pero asumiendo
ocupar el estado para deconstruir ese
estado racial patriarcal
misógino machista excluyente que hemos
tenido que no nos ha permitido a la
mayoría de los colombianos vivir en
dignidad sentía y entonces
pues estamos impulsando nuestra
candidatura a la presidencia estamos
compitiendo con gustavo petro y arely
juliana y otros precandidatos que hacen
parte de esa coalición pues tejemos
juntos en esa coalición pero estamos
compitiendo en una consulta la que gane
saquen la mayor votación el 13 de marzo
o el que gane y saque la mayor votación
el 13 de mayo será el candidato o la
candidata yo espero que colombia asume
este desafío histórico y que esta vez
las mujeres negras racial izadas
empobrecidas que representamos a
sectores o históricamente oprimidos de
esta sociedad podemos darnos la
oportunidad de llevar a la presidencia a
una mujer negra en esta construcción de
esta nueva colombia de hecho actualmente
las encuestas
opciones a que una opción progresista
como el pacto histórico pueda gobernar
con colombia que representaría esto para
el país
bueno yo creo que representa un cambio
un cambio
primero para que la paz sea una paz
completa porque estamos cansados de
sufrir con este conflicto armado y ahora
no sabemos de dónde viene la bala porque
el gobierno del presidente igual duque
hizo trizas las posibilidades de la paz
y hoy eso se traduce en la pérdida de
las vidas tanto de líderes sociales de
líderes ambientales líderes indígenas
descendientes
campesinos de jóvenes y empobrecidos y
racializados de los barrios populares
que ahora en el estadio social en el
paro fueron asesinados más de 48 jóvenes
a manos del estado colombiano y el
asesinato sistemático de los ex
combatientes que decidieron deponer sus
armas para darse paso a construir otro
camino posible para este país entonces
ese es un propósito es un propósito
asumir los desafíos de la crisis
ambiental en este país no podemos seguir
profundizando que se agote la vida en el
planeta y creemos que como mujeres
feministas
antipatriarcales
anticoloniales estamos impulsando que
una política para la vida se ponga en el
centro y eso implica transformar la
matriz energética en una economía para
la vida que pase por establecer un
sistema de producción
agroecológico en este país donde la
soberanía alimentaria hacia uno de los
renglones principales de la economía y
no el extractivismo
entendiendo que hoy hay más de 2
millones de personas que todos los días
se acuestan con hambre en este país con
tanta biodiversidad con tanto para
producir esperamos que este camino que
estamos haciendo nos permita asumir de
manera concreta una política de
reparación histórica frente a los
efectos del colonialismo del racismo y
del patriarcado que no nos ha permitido
a la gente racial izadas más de 13
millones entre afrodescendientes
vivir en dignidad esperamos que esto
permita el reconocimiento de los
derechos del campesinado colombiano
esperamos avanzar con este proyecto es
una reforma agraria pero no solamente
reforma agraria
necesitamos una reforma agraria
ecológica y feminista que ponga la
distribución de la tierra
manuel a las mujeres y por tanto hoy
estamos asumiendo desde mi candidatura a
la presidencia el mandato nacional
feminista de las mujeres que va desde la
justicia de género que sea económica
pero también de construcción del sistema
cartel ante termina judicial izando a
las mujeres en términos internacionales
es muy importante saber que aquí no se
va a lograr si no se resuelve el
problema de las drogas ilícitas y eso
pasa por romper el paradigma de la
política antidrogas y el narcotráfico
que por año no han resuelto nada y pasar
a una política de transformación del uso
de la hoja o para de la marihuana e
incluso comestible en uso medicinal y
que eso fortalezca las economías en esos
territorios
empobrecidos y violentas
francia ha sido activista desde niña y
ahora es cuando has dado el salto a la
política institucional y ha recibido
muchos ataques incluso también desde
dentro del pacto histórico que te has
encontrado en esta nueva etapa en la
política institucional y más
concretamente como os puede ser que un
gobierno tan tan diverso pueda tener
estabilidad si en caso de salir adelante
vuestra candidatura
bueno el patriarcado no es algo que nace
con el pacto histórico el patriarcado
está instaurado en la sociedad como una
forma de opresión como una vez asimismo
como el racismo como una forma de
opresión de unos seres que se ponen
sobre otros usando esas estructuras de
poder y en ese sentido creo que pues al
interior del pacto histórico seguir
haciendo los esfuerzos por romper esas
posturas patriarcales que a veces
pues también irradian en sectores
alternativos
es una necesidad
pero también una alternativa para
construir desde ese lugar reconociendo
esa violencia reconociendo estas
situaciones hacia una transformación de
país de sociedad eso es lo que
representas hoy porque somos eso es lo
que representa mi candidatura en el
pacto histórico y eso es lo que
precisamente estamos haciendo
tristemente pues este país no sabe hacer
política sin violencia
y usar la violencia hacia las mujeres
que decidimos levantar la voz que
decidimos ponernos de pie para caminar
porque algo parte de las mujeres de las
manos callosas de las regiones de los
territorios de la raíz pues cuando nos
ponemos de pie del patriarcado se
levanta en contra de nosotras pero el
desafío que tenemos como sociedad es ir
más allá y es poder garantizar que tanto
hombres como mujeres como comunidades
diversas el gp y pumas puedan tener
garantías derecho en esa sociedad
tenemos que refundar una nueva sociedad
un nuevo estado nación que nos permita
vivir a todos los colombianos y
colombianas con alegría en paz con
justicia con equidad con igualdad este
es el camino que estamos haciendo esa es
la política que estamos irrumpiendo hoy
una política que no se teje de
estructura sino que se teje desde el
boja voz de los territorios desde las
gentes la gente es de a pie tú misma has
estado no todo el rato de violencias de
liderazgos incluso tú fuiste desplazada
de tu comunidad por tu lucha contra la
minería además en colombia como es
histórico cuando llegan las elecciones
crece también la violencia quería
preguntarte si has sentido miedo por
esta exposición pública que estás
teniendo ahora en con tu candidatura
pues en toda la vida nosotros hemos
crecido en una política y por lo menos
estos 20 años que yo tengo
de estar viendo la política hegemónica
del uribismo ha sido la política del
miedo aquí nos han metido miedo por todo
miedo no solo de las violencias armas y
no miedo en términos de cuestiones de
espejo miedo en términos de reconocer
los derechos de las mayorías o sea que
no se ha hecho una política sin miedo yo
creo que el desafío que hoy tenemos es
vencer el miedo sembrar esperanzas para
ir de la resistencia al poder ese es
nuestro mayor desafío que tenemos y que
en eso estamos enfocados en eso estamos
trabajando con todas nuestras fuerzas y
bueno como ser humano como cualquier
persona que tiene sentimientos pues el
miedo es parte de la vida tenemos miedo
a que este país no también tenemos miedo
a que la violencia se siga imponiendo
tenemos miedo a que nuestros hijos
tengan que sufrir seguir sufriendo
en un estado que no es capaz de
brindarle garantía tenemos miedo a que
como colombianos y colombianas no seamos
capaces de transitar nuestras
diferencias a partir del diálogo sino
que se siga reproduciendo la violencia
armada política colom económica de
género racial y
francia- márquez muchísimas gracias ha
sido un verdadero placer hablar contigo
muchas gracias a ustedes hoy porque
somos como pueblo no nos rendimos para
como bailan y muchas gracias también a
nuestra audiencia pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en france 24 ifrán
34 punto com
[Música]